kim jong-un can never exist without
chinese communist parties of sponsorship
there's
no way he can be dictated right now and
he's imprisoning 25 millions of people
and the united nations they are saying
only resemblance we can see what's
happening to north korean people is a
holocaust
that's what holocaust is happening again
north korea and the world is denying
your gain
and the mainstream of course hollywood
and media deny it because they don't
want to like upset china
and then how were you sort of welcomed
into
into the western world after this i mean
now
you live in chicago now your your
friends we have a ton of
similar friends that are that are all
fighting these battles but but you've
lived through
this battle how did how did you go from
just sort of activism
in south korea to to where you are now
yeah in south korea unfortunately i was
heavily heavily discriminated
and i couldn't fit in i had to lie to
people that i was
south korean because they were you know
so many things like
south korea were discriminated against
for north koreans
and that's why i chose to come to
america even though people say this is
like a racist country
this is the country i've been we're most
embraced and included in my life
so i chose uss my home because like
there's no racism for me here to
experience
right so before we get to the the
non-racism of the united states so
so south koreans were discriminating
against north koreans
was that was that simply because they
didn't know north koreans or they felt
that too many north koreans were coming
over or
what is that because a lot you don't
really think that there would be that
type of discrimination
just because we are coming from a poor
country
and you know south koreans uh they
disagree against
like southeast asians like vietnamese
thailand and thai
filipinos and north koreas or support
countries i don't think they
discriminate people as much when they
come from france or
europe or like western europe or like
usa
but would have been people coming from
poor country
so we are even though we are same people
when i went to south korea they were
just making fun of my accent
because i was speaking with northern
accent and you know they were
asking me like are you spy why are you
talking to me
and it's like if i was bad why would i
even escape
so it was very tough right
so what put you on my radar was a few
months ago a whole bunch of people
started sending me a video of you
talking about your
your adventure and your journey and
everything else and you happen to
to mention that you read don't burn this
book and that
it helped you in some way which is i
don't even have the words to
to explain my gratitude for that i mean
it's it's
just beyond imagination considering what
you've lived through but
in essence you are now here in the
united states
do you consider yourself an activist
first like what do you consider yourself
now really
you're an author obviously and you're
out there fighting all these battles but
what do you consider yourself now i'm a
fighter i'm trying to fight against
north korean dictatorship and chinese
communist party that sponsors
dictatorship in north korea
and i think that's why i began i mean on
chair
i read your book and it was uh i was
more trying to be
you know what i tried to do my best to
raise awareness
and at hollywood everybody they don't
pick up north korean story like they
talk about slavery and they talk about
like
malala who was shot by taliban they talk
about was captured by isis
and michelle obama understanding of boko
haram girls
all these people in the mainstream
standing up for a lot of girls
and like human trafficking issues but
nobody here in like west
wants to talk about north korea because
that upsets chinese region
is it yeah is that crazy for you like
you come here
and you see the sort of fear around
talking not not just about north korea
but we talked about this a little
a little bit a couple weeks ago just
that you see the way we we
are afraid of speaking up here in the
freest country in the world
about whatever it might be yeah i mean
that's like
that's so shocking to me like i thought
america was like
land of the free the home of the brave
right that's like how i thought of this
country to be in coming here and like
the movies when they make about north
korea to exposing the dictatorship the
hollywood
like drop the sponsorship and there's no
way i can
like talk about because there isn't kim
jong can never exist
without chinese communist parties of
sponsorship there's no way
he can be dictated right now and he's
impressing 25 millions of people
and the united nations they are saying
only resemblance we can see what's
happening to north korean people is a
holocaust
that's what holocaust is happening again
north korea and the world is denying
your gain
and the mainstream of course hollywood
and media deny
because they don't want to like upset
china yeah
i mean is it that obvious like it's that
they just
hollywood just wants chinese dollars the
last transformers movie
you know they really wanted to push to
china so they filmed part of it there
and they put all the products and all
that kind of stuff
i mean is it really that simple it just
comes down to money and they see a new
market there and that's it
so that's like what i only recall was
like discovered last few years
that i've been keep trying to talk to
people and then as soon as i talk about
the my experience china as being you
know human trafficking all of that they
were like oh i cannot put my name on
that
and it's behind doors i was like oh i
cannot like i i care about what you do
but like
i can never like support you on this and
they have no problem supporting like
a lot of other cultures and also though
i work
i mean my movie has been trying to make
and other movies were being made already
and this major production companies gave
money and then as soon as they were like
purchased by like
these other platforms they just dropped
the sponsorship and they said i cannot
show this movie
so when you see like you know there was
the big controversy
six or seven months ago with the nba
players that wouldn't criticize
china and yet they'll tell you how
racist and everything else america is
it must it must just blow your mind i
mean
but even though it blew my mind i
couldn't speak out because i was scared
you know like they're gonna what how am
i gonna like i need to fight for my
people
what if all this country gonna make me a
cia spy and blabla you know being a
racist all of that like how do i even
get a chance to fight for my people
maybe i still need to be
like somehow being acceptable to them
but like and real i was robbed in
chicago this year during the summer
almost
and i was punched by these two black
women
and then and then and then i was trying
to ask them like can you like i was
asking people hey
she was punching me and taking my wallet
away and these people were starting
calling me a racist
like this like middle of the chicago
michigan avenue i still have a footage
of this curse
and they said you are racist you're a
bad person while you're doing this like
color of skin doesn't make them thief i
was like
i mean i have nanny who's muslim i'm
doing hijab like i'm a colorado person
like why would i do that and of course
those girls were safe
the police got the fridge of them using
my credit card spending
three thousand dollars at pulling the
like blooming there or something
yeah and i just couldn't believe it like
the people were seeing me this i was
very petted as you saw me this
big three black women were like pushing
the car and punching me and then they
still calling me racist and like
they're holding me down so they can run
away so i cannot call the police on them
and that's like oh my gosh i cannot
believe that i have a son in this
country like this is not a safe country
anymore
like things are not like okay anymore
so what what do you make about what's
happening in the united states because
one of the things we were talking about
a couple weeks ago
is that the the chill around free speech
that just people are
you said to me i think this is exactly
what you said but correct me if i'm
wrong
i mean you said this is right now
feeling like
what it felt like i i know this feeling
from from like before i say always i get
like first thing my mom taught me was
not even whisper because the birds and
mice could hear me
in north korea and now i'm same thing
like trying to teach my son like
when you cross the like walkway and you
know like crosswalk there's like
white man like walking sign and he's
like weirdo of course
he's like a white color and man looking
so it's a white man i can't walk and
people looking and i was like you cannot
say you're
that name like you know i'm always
teaching him to be
how not to be attacked and like this is
what exactly my mom did to me
like i just like and what also what i
see in america is that
when i was born in north korea i was
like third generation of this oppression
i didn't even know what the alternative
was like
but my grandmother knew like she was on
living under the japanese colonization
before kim she lived their life
and people at that time who knew what
was different
existed they stopped and they escaped
silent
and by the time when it came to us we
didn't even know that we were slaves to
dictator and that's the thing we say
like why there's no revolution in north
korea and i was like
how do you fight when you don't know
you're a slave if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about international issues instead of
non-stop yelling check out our
international playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell